okay so welcome to the panel on next
generation from robotics our three
panelists work at the intersection of AI
machine learning and robotics and I'll
ask you so first to introduce yourself
just want to come in closer or not it's
okay all right thanks so I'll ask you
that to first introduce yourself and
your research area and let's start with
Angela can you hear me okay yes hello
everyone my name is Angela sherig I'm a
professor in aerospace engineering at
the University of Toronto and affiliated
with a vector Institute my research is
at the intersection of robotics machine
learning and control theory I mean
really we are motivated to enhance the
capabilities of robots and enable them
to operate in more complex environments
and so in if you come to my lap you see
robots moving you see flying vehicles
self-driving vehicles mobile
manipulators and so that keeps us really
grounded and realistic and also allows
us to discover really serious open
problems in robot learning and we try to
address those so for example how can you
guarantee a robot learns in the real
world but that's so safely how can we
make robot learning more data efficient
how do we deal with the different
timescales of faster rotation and long
term learning and so these are kind of
the problems that they are interested in
and I guess more recently also how do we
do learning more efficiently in
interactive tasks
I recently joined the University of
Alberta and Amy so it's working
can you hear me oh great yeah so I
joined University of Alberta and Amy my
background is in reinforcement learning
so I did my PhD in RL and I was always
deeply passionate about creating
tangible intelligent systems so after I
was done with my PhD I joined a Canadian
robotic startup called kindred and there
I gained experience on how to build
learning systems that can be deployed to
a robot to solve closed-loop control
tasks using real time interactions as
opposed to learning from simulations are
learning from human demonstrations so
after that now I'm back to academia so
now my long-term goal is to develop
general and constructive mechanisms for
continually improving robot minds so one
way to talk about generality is think
about our like ourselves we are
different people we have different
emotions and different memories and we
also differ from other animals so are we
different because we have different
mechanisms for processing information or
because we have different past
experience and past like evolutionary
history so it would be lovely if we
could explain ourselves in terms of only
a few set of mechanisms and we are we
differ only because of our past
experience and evolution so I don't want
to get too controversial but to talk
about generality is much easier when we
talk about robots so here my goal is to
develop a single system that I can
deploy on different robots to solve
different tasks as opposed to focusing
on one particular robot and transferring
my understanding to the robot that's my
research oh yeah thank you hello
everyone I am Animesh gorg I started as
faculty in computer science at
University of Toronto and also at Victor
Institute a lot of the work that I do
corresponds manipulation robot
manipulation to be precise and the
driving question is the computation
underpinnings of decision making in
dexterous motor control in other words
what are the technical questions that
still need to be answered for us to be
able to build let's say a robot that can
achieve the dexterity of a
seven-year-old child and that requires a
variety of technical problems that are
across fields from reinforcement
learning imitation learning the regular
questions or the off sighted problems of
efficiency transfer of Paulinus all of
those come up the other set of problems
that actually come up in building robot
manipulation or robot manipulators is
also the ability to handle perceptual
input it can be vision haptics and and
how do you handle and represent these
inputs in a manner that is fairly
general domain independent and yet
useful and finally a lot of the problems
intersect with core problems in machine
learning where an often-cited debate is
should we be using models should be not
be using models if we are using models
then what sort of functional
approximator should we be using how to
combine these ideas with generative
models causality and and these sort of
form the pillars of what I would call
algorithmic research but as in robotics
as Angela pointed out a lot of the
things are also have to be grounded in
reality you really have to build it if
it doesn't work it's really not a robot
so I work in domains such as person
robots in surgical robotics where the
idea is to build infrastructure that
needs to work not in 50 years but
hopefully intend and that involves
building
are putting together components that
come from both machine and in computer
vision perhaps reinforcement learning
and other die ideas in decision-making
into a singular system that needs to
perform at certain levels and it also
gives us problems newer problems to
solve in these domains Thanks so when I
look at here your CVS and your web pages
in preparation it was clear to me that
you all could be anywhere in the world
so I'll ask you that the CFR question
let me start with a roux pump so why
Canada and then why is there
particularly IDEs to where you are why
is that the right place for you rather
than somewhere else in the world so I
believe that understanding building to
build understanding around mind and
intelligence and to have a carrier in AI
we need to have long term vision and I'm
continually impressed by the commitment
of Canada to long term things such as
like the desire to have clean
environment or a healthy society and I
think that depend Canadian AI strategy
is it's not a new thing it's part of
that vision and that attracted me and
University of Alberta and Amy they're
part of that vision
I'd say especially let's look at the
model of University of Alberta
whatsoever things are true right so the
commitment to true naturally would lead
us to care about long-term things and
Amy of embodies that and that's what
attracted me it helps me think deeply
thanks Angela
I think we all know that we don't do
research in isolation so the environment
metals a lot and that means colleagues
students the funding environment and so
I think that that was just very
attractive at the University of Toronto
there's I mean clear excellence in
machine learning but also in control
theory and it's a really leading
institution in field robotics so that
was quite exciting I also love the
breadth of the University
because robotics ultimately can impact
many different application areas so
seeing the breaths within the university
is really nice I think to add to both of
those points and this has been repeated
since the morning of course the ability
to do longer-term research was one of
the things but I think one of the new
things may be in addition to this was
the number of young vibrant colleagues
was exceptional it was not present in
any other place I interviewed the number
all of these people were extremely
excited about what they did and it was a
very diverse set of things that they did
so that's that's one thing and then all
of them being leaders in what they do
you put them in the same room that that
creates an environment that is also an
unparalleled so it's very easy to go and
talk to people without sending them
emails to make meet next Thursday that
that makes that changes the dynamic of
how things work and and now put all of
that together with the ability to
attract world-class talent that is
another yet in the sort of what I would
call research needs to be done not with
just at least but also students and
postdocs and we need to be able to
attract them and and that helped a
vector helped here and now put all of
that in extremely cool City
so it's it's unparalleled in that sense
that C's preferring to Toronto in case
that ya see Animus you mentioned
students let me pursue that a little
further so but the three of you are both
that are all three of you are are fairly
recent PhD grads so what advice would
you give to students in your field and
maybe you could elaborate and talk about
best practices what did you learn from
your supervisor
what will you pass along to your
students and they may be specific to
your field or just in general do you
wanna start enemy sure one of the things
I noted and this is something that has
become one of the things that all of the
students I work with is pick a problem
it may be hard to to find what you want
to
work on because there are so many things
to do and so many cool things to do but
once you pick a problem stick to it do
not switch often the first paper will be
easy these people the students are very
smart getting the first paper will be
almost always easy it's the second and
the third prob paper that would be
harder and it's almost always that the
first time a student works on the first
paper that will not be the
earth-shattering result you'll probably
want to keep working on the same problem
for at least two or three years before
something interesting happens and and in
current climate it's very easy to keep
sort of checking off the publication
list but keep switching areas because
there's enough sort of hot topics and
that doesn't really help much so stick
to it stick to one problem and don't
always chase the hot topic unless you're
going to stick it so build a reputation
in a specific sub field not just
reputation you don't yourself understand
the problem unless you've written three
papers about this yeah so what I learned
from my supervisor I and I want to pass
it along which is that the students they
should think about what will be their
role in the future of AI right so there
are so many things that are happening
but there are also some problems that
are long-standing and they do not get
solved even by the most advanced deep
reinforcement learning algorithms and
there's so many of them and rather to
focus on them than say being distracted
by easy success that would be something
I would advise I think my goes a little
bit in this direction and I think I
really encourage students to ask their
own questions because very often the
longer you work in a certain field the
more you are influenced but the current
trends and directions but I think
especially as young grad students
learning about the topics you really
come across these questions obvious
potentially obvious questions why things
are not yet tackled or not have not been
solved and so you're asking your own
questions I think it's really important
and then also being eye
try to encourage students to be honest
and really discussed the advantages but
also limitations of their work because
only if we are honest about the
limitations we can move make progress in
the future Thanks so as far as I
understand all three of you are
full-time academics correct and you how
did you choose whether to go into
industry or the academic world why did
you choose the way you did who would
like to start you have any any thoughts
Angela could I pick on you to start yes
so my mind was kind of a coincidence in
the sense that I had never made up my
mind about joining industry or academia
but then the academic job came faster
than then I could even apply for
industry so that's kind of how it
happened but I really enjoy I guess the
freedom of collaborating with people I
like to collaborate with and answering
questions that I think are excited it is
exciting but I do think you know there's
so much interesting things happening on
the industry side and the the trends
that we see that people flow back and
forth I think is very good for
ultimately for progress we like to go I
for full disclosure I still spent some
time at Nvidia so it's not completely
one side but I think the decision was as
a junior researcher I really like to be
able to work on a research vision
sometimes that requires a team sometimes
that requires you to think beyond just
say one or two or three years and also
not just working on one or two projects
that was something that was only
afforded as an opportunity to be the
university rather than let's say at any
other companies perhaps if you have a
hundred person team a deep mind yes
you could probably execute the vision
there as well at the same time in the
last few years we have seen that equally
good research and perhaps sometimes
exciting research
happening on either end of the spectrum
so it's not necessarily better it's it's
just a choice I think yeah yeah so I
came back from industry so I feel like
both are important and I still see the
value of having both for example in the
industry I when I work at kindred I
worked on something by which all of us
at kindred got benefitted by a lot for
example kindred the production team
they've got a technology of powerful
technology that essentially like change
their game in for their production robot
on the other hand I obtained a lot of
problems to solve right so now they're
focusing more on idolizing that
technology for the production robot well
I have I am now et lysing the the
problem that I gained and tried to solve
them in the academia so I think this
back and forth or at least having a
direct line with the industry or being
keep keeping in touch with it is quite
valuable Thanks
so I think we all agree that the AI
machine learning robotics has incredible
promise right for society and is
happening now right now and also perhaps
a lot of peril for a society so if I
could ask you what would you not want to
see if you're willing to say it in the
next five years I'm not asking you to
really make a prediction but just what
would you be uncomfortable with your
where your field would go what kind of
applications and then and then to keep
it positive after that what would you
like to see what do you hope to see in
in five years that will benefit society
broadly speaking who would like to go
first
I can go first robotics in the current
set up a lot of the times the way market
forces work or the way it is being
developed or at least the motivations
for such development can often be
weather implicit or explicit designed
for job displacement especially at the
lowest rung of the jobs that would be
kind of a societal bad decision and on
the upside there are certain areas where
human augmentation would be a very good
idea and human augmentation in both
cognitive and physical sense so certain
jobs are indeed actually treacherous or
or just like should not be done by
humans they are being done by humans
just because there's other ones that are
existing and need to get done so of
course there are more high tech versions
of these things where this is surgery
and Surgeons but also sanitation or or
mining and often even even at this point
stuff that is warehouse fulfillment all
of this is not necessarily the best of
the jobs and it's worthwhile to work on
technology to replace the fix
Thanks yeah so I want to address a
little bit on the job displacement think
so
kindred they have a production robot and
it is deployed in the wire houses of say
egapp the Apple company and their
warehouses are in the middle of us and
what happened what happens there is that
like during the peak season they don't
actually have enough people to work and
by having these robots so that does come
from gap they're saying that there they
still have this shortage of labor
problem but the few people they have
they become more productive by working
together with robots so oftentimes it is
actually not quite the way we think that
it will truly replace job and the thing
that I wouldn't want to see after five
years is that what we are seeing today
in the robotics industry which is the
industry in the robotics industry
companies they focus typical
on one particular robot and they try to
solve one task and if you set up like if
you have a start-up for that it will
take like years to build an engineering
team and the platform to just to begin
your production and if we continue doing
that so that's not good we want some
scalable technology so that a company
can easily move around different
applications and each time you do not
take like years to build a team so
that's one thing so what I want to see
instead is from reinforcement learning
community will have enough
demonstrations directly applied to
robots for learning in real time so that
the robot manufacturers they get
inspired to rebuild their infrastructure
so that their software and hardware they
are compatible to learning so that their
hardware can be used for exploration and
their software like the default
controller they provide I hope that that
includes some pre learned reflexes or
some features which can be further
modified or learned with more experience
so that's what I would like to see in
five years I think I start with what I
want to see in fact I feel so I'd like
to see more robots in our human centric
environment so right now the majority of
robots are still in kind of factory
environments and so doing your next step
in getting robots closer to us and
helping us I mean self-driving cars is
one direction but any kind of a mobile
manipulation in in less structured
environments and I guess the danger is
that we go too fast in robotics because
then you know robots ultimately machines
that physically interact with the world
so they can also how make big a harm
than other machine learning systems so I
think we just have to be careful to not
I guess destroy the progress by having
failures that are too traumatic such
that we the research field will be
harmed
Thanks so my my timer says that I've
used that more time than I was supposed
to but let me open it up for some
questions from you the audience before
we break for lunch so that was sort of a
incentive there to ask your questions
are there any questions are you all one
to have lunch now in case that was a
mistake on my part okay I should have
planted a question and I didn't that's
okay
so that's before I break that let I just
want to put in a plug for Angela's
website she has these great videos on
YouTube but you can look at so please do
that and let's thank our panelists
[Applause]